Hãy bỏ tương anh như kia 3 ngờ em chỉ tham một giữ kiến hội đàn với chủ tịch Trung Quốc tập cận mình tại mắc kinh trong lựa cả hệ của nãy sống phương vốn căng thẳng nhiều năm qua.
Đây là chuyến tham Trung Quốc đồng tiền của một thu tương anh kể từ năm 2018, được đường kỳ vọng mở ra các cơ hội kinh tế mới.
Theo kêu hạnh không 3 ngờ có cuộc gặp theo dài vàng bống me phố đếm tập tại đại lệ lệ lệ lượng nhân dân sau đó dùng bự chứa và lạm biệt với thu tổng Trung Quốc li cơm,
cũng không chụt tệ con hội chiều lạc đế, hãy bình dụt kiến công vốn thuật hợp tác, nhằm ngăn chạm cho mạng lệ bôn người tập trung vào việc kiểm soát muốn cùng đậm gơ sản xuất đại Trung Quốc,
cho các chiến thình nhỏ được sự giục nè cười đối tượng phạm đối tổ chức vượt viên từ cho lâu sáng anh.
Truyến tham tuyến ra trong bối cảnh anh đang tìm cách thu kại tắng trở về đế.
Đồng thời có thể về Mỹ sất hiện càng thẳng mới sau cắt trên mũ với chánh gái của tổng thống Mỹ đồ đàn trăm.
Chí phủ anh cho rằng cần xây dựng mùi quanh hệ trường thành với Trung Quốc,
cân bằng giữa hợp tác tiền đế và các quần gại về án lình với nhân quyền.
Mặc gình cùng phát đến hợp sản sản gái trên quanh hệ, vọt nơi là thời điểm thàn chốt để tăng cường lọc tên chỉ chỉ chỉ và hợp tác thích chất.